donc là c'est moi dans le temple quatre
là c'est moi dans le temple 6 ici c'est
moi dans le temple 1,1 à combien des
temples bas il y en a 17 là là c'est moi
dans le temple 6 voilà n'entend plus 5
pardon mc c'est super intéressant c'est
des sites touristiques incontournables
en amérique centrale
mais tu sais pour les archéologues c'est
plus intéressant n'imaginait qu'un
temple maya sait que la partie émergée
de l'iceberg ce que et qu' il ya bien
plus à apprendre de ce qu'on ne voit pas
mais tu sais que j'ai rencontré des
chercheurs qui ont fait des découvertes
de folie sur les maillages juste en
étudiant la forêt tropicale 2018 marque
un tournant dans la connaissance de la
civilisation maya
une collaboration internationale de
scientifiques entrepris de cartographier
le relief du sol sur plus de 2000
kilomètres carrés en zone maya dans ce
qu'on appelle les basses terres
centrales entre le guatemala le mexique
et le belize le bon le belize
si c'est un pays d'ailleurs on devrait
en parler plus souvent c'est vraiment
bien le bénisse et pour étudier une
telle zone recouverte de forêts denses
les scientifiques ont recours à la
technologie lidar clotilde tu peux
m'aider à expliquer ce que c'est le
lidar le lidar est une technique
d'imagerie qui permet d'enregistrer les
micros relief du sol quand on n'a pas
accès directement aux vestiges qu'ils
sont indétectables par photos aériennes
comme c'est le cas pour la plupart des
sites mayas recouverts par la végétation
et bien le lidar peut être une solution
concrètement c'est un laser embarquer
dans un avion ou un drone qui survole la
forêt ainsi on peut modéliser à partir
d'un nuage de points lidar 3d du sol des
sites archéologiques et leur
environnement
en somme le lidar qui est l'acronyme
pour light detection and ranging fait
partie des oui bon bah ça va fait partie
des diverses techniques employées par
l'archéologie environnementale et la
géoarchéologie mais je vous parle un peu
plus de ça dans un épisode qui vous
attend sur ma chaîne deux jeunes ont été
cartographiées par lidar et à partir de
ces modèles numériques de terrain une
équipe scientifique franco guatémaltèque
s'est intéressé plus particulièrement
aux sites mayas de nash ball
merci et ça donne ça
et là que n'ont ils pas découvert des
cités mayas engloutis non c'est pas vrai
mais ils ont réussi à identifier tout un
tas de construction qui était invisible
jusqu'à présent est ce qui est
surprenant c'est que le peuplement est
beaucoup plus dense que ce que l'on
pensait sur les 135 kilomètres carrés de
la zone de nash thoune
on retrouve les vestiges de plus de
douze mille habitations soit une densité
de population de l'ordre de celle de
salon de provence ou de nogent le rotrou
leurs trousses
c'est une ville on ne parle pas assez
des salles vous paraît peut-être pas
énorme mais jusqu'ici les chercheurs
pensaient que la population mayas
étaient regroupés dans des cités très
densément peuplées celle que nous
visitons aujourd'hui et dans quelques
zones résidentielles attenante
le reste des terres étaient deux grands
champs cultivés en agriculture plus
intensive est occupé par une population
paysanne plutôt éparses en réalité les
images il d'art montrent une forte
densité de la population sur tout le
territoire de nash thoune on voit ici de
nombreuses habitations y compris dans
les zones éloignées du centre de la cité
que l'on pensait jusque-là dédié
simplement à l'agriculture seules les
zones inondables les barreaux ce ne
semble pas occupé vous imaginez à quel
point cette découverte change notre
vision de la civilisation maya
on pensait avoir affaire aux châteaux de
la loire et on se retrouve face aux
banlieues pavillonnaires du val de loire
mais attention ces structures n'ont pas
forcément été utilisée tout en même
temps oui petit rappel la civilisation
maya se développe sur trois millénaires
résultat ce que vous voyez sur ses
relevés n'est pas toujours de la même
époque
les scientifiques se sont alors
intéressés aux vestiges de
l'exploitation des terrains et des
ressources en eau faille bien est loué
en analysant les reliefs
ils ont découvert dans les secteurs de
collines plus de 19000 terrasses
agricoles réparties dans toute la zone
habitée et dans les marais plus de 5400
canaux d'irrigation et de drainage près
de 900 réservoir sans compter des chants
des bassins et désigne les habitants de
nation'' exploiter donc les terres de
façon intensive et avait en plus
développé un système de gestion de l'eau
leur permettant de traverser les rues
tables et aléatoire saison sèche enfin
les chercheurs ont identifié deux
longues chaussée surélevée des routes
qui relient les cités principale entre
elles et qui constitue un maillage dense
qui quadrillent la zone sur plus de 60
kilomètres de long l'analyse des modèles
numériques de terrain obtenu grâce aux
lidar permet donc d'avoir une vision des
paysages et de la société maïa dans les
basses terres très différente de celle
de l'archéologie classique
en fait c'est un peu un leurre de croire
que toute la vie tourne autour des
temples
alors que franchement le paysan maya
après sa journée de boulot ils
rentraient direct dans son pavillon de
banlieue
oui c'est vrai les prochaines campagnes
de fouilles permettront de dater plus
précisément l'occupation de nation'' et
de compléter ce nouveau modèle
d'urbanisme et de gestion
environnementale du territoire maya tu
sais il faut pas toujours chercher le
savoir dans les temples il est parfois
juste devant son chant 7 qui ces
citations on m'a seulement
et si ce sujet vous a intéressé
n'hésitez pas à les voir l'épisode sur
la chaîne de clotilde passé sauvage et
abonnez-vous aux deux chaînes